it's another example of how technocracy
is leading us to to communism because
what happens is the media chooses what
Clips get shared over and over and over
again and what can't be shared I tried
to talk about the things the media you
mean we'll say social media algorithms
meta for instance censored my posts
trying to talk about the fentanyl in his
system the guy was doing an eight ball
or with a speedball that's the rules it
takes behind the wheel of a car so like
the media that got pushed out was the
few minutes that he can't breathe I
can't breathe I can't breathe people go
crazy and then the the cops the job of
the law enforcement is like protect the
peace they don't care about who's guilty
or sent they don't want riots so they
Yep this this Tau Tau is going to prison
because they just want to avoid more
social breakdown that means understand
this if you live in a city like
Minneapolis if you live in a city like
Portland OR Seattle and you are an a
victim of violent crime from the likes
of a far-left extremist or even just a
run-of-male criminal you could be the
victim and there is no out for you you
fight back you go to jail